Britain is now laying the foundations
for the post proxied economy and the
most controversial topic of all is
finally being broached immigration new
rules from the Home Office mean
low-skilled European workers like these
Romanian builders will no longer have
freedom of movements
indeed the chances are they wouldn't be
able to come here at all and that is
causing a real headache in the industry
which is supposed to be rebuilding the
housing market getting skilled people
from the UK where you don't find that
difficult what we find very difficult is
the jobs which the British do not want
to do nobody wants to work in the core
British weather nobody wants to work in
freezing conditions work outdoors so
unfortunately that's the difficulty that
we've had it is in other words a
controversial issue but the Home
Secretary says it is a crucial element
of Britain's post brexit settlement this
is the first time in decades the
government has been able to take back
control run its own immigration system
after we've left the European Union and
free movement and low skilled migration
to our country which means that we will
get migration numbers down but how does
the new points-based system actually
work well if you want a visa you'll need
to get up to 70 points how well a job
offer gives you 20 having the right
skills give it to you another 20 speak
good English and you'll get another 10
so 50 in total and then if you want to
get to 70 you could have a salary over
twenty five thousand six hundred pounds
or if you work in a field where there's
a shortage of workers like a nurse or a
maths teacher you get bumped up to same
thing if you've got a PhD in science and
tech sounds complicated but actually in
a sense it's quite familiar now when you
look beyond the facade actually this new
immigration policy rather resembles the
last one that dates back from the new
labour area you still gonna have a job
in order to come here unless you've got
a high skill level you've got to pass a
certain salary threshold the main
difference of course is that nowadays it
will apply to EU citizens as well and
actually that is a big shift so we got
the kitchen here another sector at the
sharp end of this is hospitality so
we're a Solomon who's
for Ghana I've got Patrick from Poland
the chances are a few stay at a hotel or
eat at a restaurant in this country at
least some of the work will have been
done by immigrants
Surinder Aurora is a second generation
immigrant who worked his way up to
become a billionaire hotel iya he doubts
his parents would have qualified for
this new scheme themselves I don't
disagree with what the government's
doing except I think we need to just
hope that the government would keep an
open mind in the coming months and years
and see well actually if he's throttling
business such as ours or other
industries have mentioned that they'll
keep an open mind and do something about
it quickly the main thing that draws
people into a country isn't the
immigration policy but the prospect of
getting a job and improving their lives
it brings economy booms after brexit so
might immigration if it slumps well that
might drive off people anyway at Conway
Sky News